des nouveautés sont à prévoir dans les
prochains mois Westfield Parly 2 le
centre commercial veut notamment
développer les espaces de restauration
les terrasses intérieures et extérieures
seront mises en place à proximité du
cinéma et de nouveaux restaurants
s'installeront progressivement à partir
de fin 2022 objectifs doubler leur
nombre dans le centre aujourd'hui nous
ne sommes plus qualifiés comme un centre
de shopping mais vraiment un centre de
destination et qui dit destination dit
bien évidemment prendre le temps et
avoir une offre de restauration vraiment
particulière de nouvelles enseignes vont
également arriver à Westfield Parly 2
entre la fin de l'année et le début
d'année prochaine on va avoir je peux
vous dire notamment Victoria Secret donc
qui est vraiment attendu de la part de
nos visiteurs on va voir café joyeux
donc je pense que tout le monde connaît
maintenant l'enseigne qu'a fait joyau on
a eu aussi énormément de rénovations que
ce soit par Afflelou de Morgan et toute
sorte d'enseigne on va également avoir
très prochainement arabianood qui est
qui propose des parfums en fait tout
simplement marché de niche qui va ouvrir
nécessairement sous peu des nouveautés
écologiques également en 2023 le centre
veut réduire de 20% sa consommation
énergétique par rapport à l'année de
référence de 2019 pour cela plusieurs
astuces vont être mises en place niveau
des éclairages finir le passage en LED
ne pas forcément allumer toutes les
lumières quand c'est pas nécessaire au
niveau des verrières par exemple quand
il fait jour à l'extérieur éteindre les
lumières sous l'arrière ces nouveautés
auront pour objectif de continuer à
faire grandir cette structure construite
en 1969 et qui attire plus de 10
millions de visiteurs chaque année